welcome to the latest episode of just
getting started right here on westwood
one i am your humble host
rich eisen last week we started this
podcast we got this baby off the ground
by talking to the academy award winner
matthew mcconaughey today
we're going to go straight into the
world of business and we're going to
talk to damon john
uh the creator of fubu he's now a shark
on shark tank as we all know he's uh a
best-selling author i'll give you the
full um i guess or him the full
introduction in a second
but in case you are somehow just new to
us and you didn't hear the first episode
go ahead and download it matthew
mcconaughey was as the kids say
lit it was great and he might have
actually been lit but at any rate long
story short
um it was thrilling to have him i love
that guy great stories and that's what
this podcast
is all about and it's going to be all
about and i hope you're going to take uh
take us up on the offer to subscribe and
uh come along
for the ride come along for the journey
here because that's what we're all
on um we're all on a journey here we're
all trying to be successful we're all
trying to make the most
of us we're trying to make the most of a
situation we're trying to make
you know a nice living and provide for
our family and live up to
maybe our dreams and a lot of us have
gotten waylaid by covid19 a lot of us
have gotten way laid by something out of
our control and sometimes maybe
it's something that we did and we're
trying to learn from so what i want this
podcast to be
is um a group of people
who you want to hear from obviously and
a bunch of stories that you're going to
enjoy hearing
as well obviously but i want you to take
something away from this
if you're somebody out there that's
looking to get started
um on your dream or try to reboot your
life or try to
change things up um that's what this
pods for
with a lot of successful people who have
taken
many different paths to success and
let's mine those roads and
try and give you something portable for
your own journey so
let's get started on this show with
damon john
he is a man with many hats including the
yankee hat that's on his head he is the
founder of
fubu he's a shark on abc's emmy
award-winning series shark tank two-time
new york times best-selling author and
the owner of the shark
group here on just getting started damon
john how are you damon
i am well i'm amazing i'm healthy and uh
thank you for asking
of course absolutely uh one last thing i
left off uh i think that uh
maybe defines you hollis queens that's
where you are from
what in the world was in the water in
hollis queens to have so many people of
note and so many successful people
coming out of that section of new york
city you know i
i don't know but what must have happened
was probably
you know once you start to see one or
two
make it you know then they have cousins
and brothers and sisters
and you just started it started to
change your way and your thought process
i think and
and for those who don't know i mean um
as i look at it it was
uh you know llc run dmc salt and pepper
try called quest 50
cents ja rule onyx uh
and so many other ed lover and dr dre
not dr dre from california but
uh mtv and then literally another
another dozen
that that came out of the same you know
square five miles
well from the sports world i don't want
to forget stephen a smith too i mean
stephen a
would be very upset if we did not
mention him uh
anthony anthony mason uh sweet pea uh
um i mean so many others also that i can
i can think about yeah
it seems so so um you have not lost the
new york accent
no matter what you i could still hear it
in your voice
damon you still got it what would you be
talking about
um it doesn't realize
i don't i didn't realize that i have an
accent i thought that everybody else
does
well no i uh when i i you know i'm from
staten island
uh i'm from another outer borough and
you could sort of hear that in my voice
right there i kind of i
kind of got it there when i first
started doing sports casting when i was
first starting my career damon
um i would say things like ncaa
tournament
or you know or the state of oregon you
know and
and i i you know i learned to have to i
had to
dial it back a little bit you know i
never thought to dial it back actually
uh you know
my wife is from uh pennsylvania and
every time i say well that's hilarious
she would say hilarious
well it's part of your roots that's part
of your origin story and that's what
this
this show's all about um is trying to
you know talk to folks like yourself who
have been so successful
about how it all started and what we can
maybe glean
from your journey so where where would
you say
your your beginnings started for the
lack of a better phrase like where do
you think it all started for you
damon well it all started growing up i
mean i was born in brooklyn but
age one i moved to hollis queens and it
all really started you know
uh there's a couple of different stages
of it one by understanding
that your day job would never make you
rich and that hard work is the only
thing in education
in any form of gravity gradually
grabbing an education was going to be
the things that are going to
help you be successful and that came
from my father who was
uh came over here from trinidad at 16
years old and swept up the streets until
he made enough money to bring his
siblings up over and my mother who is a
one of three but had all the
hand-me-downs from the two boys in the
in the house and my uh and you know my
great-grandmother was a slave
and um you know that is one part of my
beginning
um being loved by by her and my parents
would get divorced and at 10 years old
i'd never see her speak to my father
ever again
and realizing that my mother was the man
of the house and my mother worked
very hard to to give me the things that
uh
you know that she could afford to give
me an education so that's one aspect of
my life
the next thing that made me was growing
up in the community of
of any community but this new emerging
technology of hip-hop
i call it technology this new emerging
way of communication called hip-hop when
i was about 10 or 12 years old that came
out of the bronx
and made its way into queens was this
this this
this way that like instagram or snapchat
we were starting to understand that the
plight that we had or the loves and the
passion we had in our community
was the same in the streets of compton
was the same in the streets of florida
but
we didn't see that on the six o'clock
news but we heard that through hip-hop
that's why i called it a new form of
technology or new delivery of
information
so what would be when did you first
realize
that um that hip-hop could be uh a
pathway
for business success damon when was when
did that start
for you well from an unrealistic
standpoint i understood that at about
15 or 16 when i first was going on
um the music tours as a as a roadie
on the music tour not getting paid but
just kind of like
running around and uh like like many
places in the country of the world
a new cheap drug started to hit the
streets called crack cocaine
and unfortunately as you and i spoke
about hollis queens being the home of a
lot of legendary people
they were actually legendary drug
dealers that president reagan
would talk about in hollis queens and
they really
took advantage of a lot of the community
but many of the young men
and women in the community uh never saw
a person of color
on tv who was successful that didn't
come from sports and had what
we feel was a great ability and a great
discipline
um so you know if i looked to tv to see
somebody that looked like me who was an
entrepreneur
it didn't really look like fred g
sanford the junk man was doing that well
uh and so if you never saw that
many of us moved over to that side of
the world
or of that world and would be dead or in
jail by
21. um i happen to go on those music
tours
the first rap music tour uh which i
don't want to date myself
gopher had fat boys on it llj
houdini and um a big daddy kane
and i went on that tour and i i realized
where and not the whole tour
let me let me explain they would have a
spotted date maybe in philadelphia maybe
troy new york or
some place like that and i would go to
one of those dates and i would see
somebody like a llc standing on stage
with 20
000 people screaming over him
waving their hands and this man was
making money and i said
you can actually make money do something
you love
doing something else you don't have to
risk everything um and that was my first
point where
i said i know that i can make money
there so i tried to be a rapper i tried
to be a break dancer and uh
obviously it didn't work out
well it's funny it's funny you say that
damon because you know when i
um realize when i first realized i
couldn't hit the curve ball
i couldn't make a jump shot i couldn't
do all that i knew i'd have to talk
about it for a living to get to where i
wanted to go
so i guess you you had the same
revelation in your
area of uh of your world huh i did i did
and i stumbled so many times and i
started so many little businesses that i
started out of the
need to want to make money and think i
was going to be a good jillionaire in
one year after this business
and they never worked out i fell on my
face
i was also the guy who was too cool in
school that after
i uh finished high school i took the one
year off of college really the party and
club and i never went
back to college and i laughed at all
those kids in school
who were applying for colleges and i
turned around i was 22 years old
i was working in red lobster and the
kids who i laughed at were coming back
and i was
serving them shrimp in red lobster with
tartar sauce on my apron
and it struck me maybe i'm the idiot
um so i never thought after
my uh you know at that point that i
would ever be a person of
the level of success that maybe i i have
now i thought that
first of all i was never going to do
anything illegal and obviously i can't
rap
so i'm going to start just working every
day nine to five or whatever it is maybe
i'll get a city job maybe i'll do
something of that nature but
that was where i found fubu because uh
i was working the day job and i was
happy with it be very honest i'm always
happy with the decisions i make
but i found a hobby called fubu because
i just love to dress people and i
wouldn't realize that i would be here
with you today
so before we get a little deeper into
that that was i guess your epiphany
moment
was at a red lobster where you're just
looking down and you're just taking
stock and it sort of hits you
that that there's a different path you
need to take in order to you
for you to achieve what you knew
at the moment like this you just felt it
in your bones like this was a moment
that you just needed to pivot
right then and there that was your
moment yeah you know i kind of did the
whole thing of you know thinking about
you know if you keep doing the same
thing getting the same results you know
uh you know what is it are you that's
called insanity
and i had to have a very humbling moment
with myself
that um you know i i still till today
keep having those moments
but i took inventory and i said if i
keep going down this path i'll never
grasp any level of success that i'm
aiming after
um and i started to settle a little bit
with maybe the rest of my life i will
you know just be a waiter and it's fine
you know that could be fine too and then
i started
you know my part of aspiration a little
bit was if i if i do a great job as a
waiter maybe
i can get into a program of hotel
restaurant management but
that was that was as high as i was
aiming at that point so where did
so now let's get to the fubu part
obviously because this is where
things begin to take a major tick
up for you and so why
fubu where did this come from and and
what where where did it all i guess
start with a big break for you if you
can walk me through that
damon well my career has been a million
big breaks uh food was started when
um i was really looking for some
clothing to wear
and um and which i had already supported
so many of the designers
out in the market at the time and then
we just started to hear this
kind of this they started to get this
backlash because we saw to hear
designers did not want people of color
wearing their clothes that they didn't
want inner city kids or rappers whatever
the case is
and i'm sure those are rumors i hope
there were rumors of most of those
companies
but then timberland uh had put in the
new york times something in the nature
of
we don't sell or make our boots for drug
dealers they're no longer owned by the
same
uh company and they they they retracted
a lot of things that they said or
attempted to
but it hurt me uh dearly because i was
spending so much money on timberland
boots because i love them almost like
the way the kids love jordans and yeezys
that i went home and i create a brand
fubu fourth bios um
and a lot of people thought initially it
was about a color but it was about a
culture it wasn't going to be
a bigot the same way i felt at that time
the comment that came out of
timberland's mouth was
and i created my brand um but but what
were the moments i mean i have so many
moments i mean the one i remember is
i sewed a bunch of hats by hand and uh
good friday 1989 3 o'clock in the
afternoon
i stood on the corner and i sold 800
worth of hats in one hour
no kidding yeah and that was the moment
i said i will never
work for anybody ever again for the rest
of my life and uh
reality set in i went back to red
lobster for another five years but the
feeling was good at that moment
so wow i love that um because
so many people are looking these days
for uh a sign and not only maybe a sign
but a way to find their
inner strength and
do something with it you know it's so
simple like to to hear
to see you where you are now and think
well this is always
going to be the case and perhaps that is
the case because you will always
gonna work hard you were always gonna
say i'm not gonna leave it up to
somebody else
but what would you say for you for
designing fubu and to to decide this is
what i'm gonna do and to find the
strength to go out on on the street
corner and sell it
where does somebody find that how how
can somebody
manufacture that if that's what's
necessary to find
their way forward damon i think that's a
good question
i don't think that i've ever been asked
that before i think that it is
starts off with you mentally knowing
your why but also putting the proper
lens
on you know what are you doing what is
the investment
and what is the worst thing that can
happen um and i think that uh you know
the day of standing on the corner
selling food with making the 800
worth of hats i would close fubu down
three times from 89 to 92
because i ran out a little bit of a
capital but i would always look at my
downside
and the end of the day i felt good about
selling people something that they felt
good about but i'm gonna tell you
be very honest why i after that for the
next
three or four years i would keep doing
it number one
i felt important because people saw me
wearing my own product i wasn't making
much money
number two is when i went onto a video
set and i only literally had the same
10 or 20 t-shirts for about two years
when they kicked everybody else off the
video set i was like i'm here to address
the artist i wasn't there to dress the
artist i was there to talk to the girls
i was there to get the free food i was
there to watch the artist i mean
most people would pay to see their
favorite artist perform
if i got to go to a video set and i got
to see run dmc or
llc perform mama said knock you out
are you kidding me this shirt is giving
me the ability to go on there
so but what i found is i kept finding
more joy and more joy in what i was
doing and then i started to find ways to
monetize that
and usually any entrepreneur or
successful person in the world
they find a joy they find tomorrow when
they educate themselves on a better
weight more way efficient way to do it
and more
ways to add value to their customer
you know i mean you've been there
already you could not be this you could
not be the rich
eisner that we all respect and value if
you weren't
opening a crackerjack box every morning
or every week when you found different
ways or different people walked up and
said rich
i love the position you did that i never
thought of that or whatever the case is
and
that is the driving force on every
single thing i do
i don't care about the downside i only
look up the upside i don't risk too much
and i'm a little bit vulnerable that's a
great way to put it too damon is
vulnerable
and not and and not being fearful
of of feeling it and and using it maybe
as a springboard to never say no
and always bet on yourself i i'll never
forget when i
was trying to get you know an honor job
on tv and uh i would just pack up my
my um my tapes my resume tapes in these
big
thick you know three-quarter inch boxes
it was huge
and i i i put it put on a suit and i i
hopped in a car and i i road tripped
upstate new york looking for just
knocking on doors of news directors
saying you know i would make sure i
wouldn't
go during a news hour because that was
definitely
a way for me to say i don't know your
business and i don't respect your
business when i show up at your busiest
time to ask for
you know your time for for me to
interview with you even though you're
not
looking to hire it really was just a
so i remember i i went and i went to
upstate new york
and i i i walked in uh to
uh somebody's house that had yet to be
um yet to be it was still a startup
because i sent a tape to a a 24 7
news uh organization that was just
formulating in the in
in albany schenectady and troy new york
you mentioned troy before um you know
and they were they were just starting it
up you know in the seat of new york
state power to
be a 24 7 news channel and i sent a tape
to them to be a sports guy and
they responded they got my tape and i
just showed up on this person's step
thinking it was a business but instead
it was his house
and i i knocked on his door and he was
in the bathroom when i showed up i swear
to god this happened
and the person who answered the door
said hold on a second i'll go get him
and i
like all in the family i heard a flush
of the toilet upstairs
he comes downstairs and he says to me to
my face i don't have time for this [ __ ]
i don't have any time for walk-ins and
slam the door in my face
and i thought i was so low i felt
so low and i sat in the car and i had a
moment
sort of what you had at the red lobster
and i'm like i am not gonna let this man
define me i will not let that happen but
i was
vulnerable i could not have been more
vulnerable at that moment and that was
that was the lowest moment
for me man when i was looking for work
big time
so i hear you and what did it do after
that
it there you know you have to have a
strong rejection muscle in any form of
success
um especially when you don't listen and
every everybody who's getting
intimidated around
intimidated right now when i say that
every parent has a strong rejection
muscle because when you deal with a
two-year-old or five-year-old
ten-year-old you gotta have a strong
protective muscle but what did that do
to build character in you why did you
get back up
i had no choice you know what i'm saying
like
i i i didn't think i had any choice and
i also firmly believed in myself
i really did i really thought i am not
going to let
this guy who might have had a bad day or
clearly
the business wasn't off the ground i
mean he was really you know
he was he's he's dropping a deuce in his
own house you know what i mean when i
went and found him to be honest with you
and i i'm like i am not gonna i
literally
thought to myself this is not gonna work
out
and then i said to myself i'm not gonna
let this be
the end of it because i'm gonna i'm not
gonna give up because of this guy
and and sure enough you know
interestingly enough i wound up getting
a job
um in reading california um i had a
great stint there and espn
hired me from there and in year two year
two of being on espn
they invited a whole bunch of media
critics from around to show up on the
sports center set and do a sports center
you know next to a real anchor just to
see how it put
them in the shoes of the of the on-air
person
and uh the person i was sitting next to
was the the the sports critic for the
albany times union
i'm like i got a question for you did
this you know
did do you have a 24 7 news television
outlet and he goes no i'm like did one
ever start would you know if one was
going to start and he goes yeah
then he goes never started and i sat
there and i just nodded my head i'm like
damn straight i didn't let that guy
take me down he never got out of his
house and i'm sitting where i wanted to
be
i i really had that moment now
now we know why it never started because
he
he did that to a lot of people and you
never know who could have walked in that
door
and thank god to you that's what i said
that damon because i'm like
what's more what's more um and
you know i guess enterprising that i
found you in your house
you know like that's the type of guy you
should say i want to hire that person
but anyway i i bring that up because you
when you say vulnerable that kind of hit
a nerve in me obviously because to me
that is important because you still have
to say vulnerable
uh is is is not a bad word
it is not it is something that can be
actually used as strength
it really can i believe that putting
yourself out it's another way of saying
being willing to learn it's it's so many
different ways than being vulnerable
and people respect that the ones who
respect it want to help
and they want to work with you and uh
not not not that it's charity or pity
you know what i mean so i i i think is
key to being an entrepreneur key to
success in life
being open to learn being vulnerable and
also having empathy for others
i guess in that respect before we move
on to the here and now a little bit here
damon what
what what was that with that moment for
you where you thought
you know you were told no or you were
rejected
or you you were made to think that your
concept of fubu
and what you were doing i know your mom
um
you know mortgaged the house to help
get you started to give you some capital
i know that that you were you
you did get some support but what what
were the moments where you thought maybe
this wasn't going to work out
for you i i created my own company and
after about um
eight years i was you know i was
frustrated i wasn't getting as far as i
could even though i had all the hype
around me but i didn't know what i
didn't know
i went over to some guys who had
answered an ad
um and um i you know they
interviewed me of doing a manufacturing
distribution deal
um and i left and i called them back you
know
and that that time was answer machines
and the guy who
ended up you know discussing it with me
didn't answer that answer machine for
about uh five months and i you know and
i just felt
totally defeated and ignored and
kind of just stupid um i would go to the
magic trade show
i'd already won one time and the magic
trade show was a trade show that we all
sell our apparel at um and i would go
six months later to that trade show
and that guy and his brother would see
me walking down the
the aisle and they happened to have a
booth where they were talking to really
big buyers like macy's and all these
people
and one of the biggest buyers in the
industry pointed over and said is that
the guy with the food shirt
to his assistant and said go get him we
have to have
that boo-boo now i don't remember
talking to that person but i went home
week later oh my god guess who calls me
i answer the phone he goes hey let's
come once come in and let's uh let's do
the deal
and i was young i was scrappy i thought
that i was mr big
entrepreneur and i i negotiated out of
ignorance
and i was just i i wouldn't have done
the deal but i was like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you didn't call me back
now all of a sudden you're calling me
you're full of whatever whatever
whatever if i come there
do not waste my time there better be a
deal signed and i don't know how long
period of time me not knowing a really
great deal you should go through some
paperwork and there should not be a yeah
sign this
right but um i got one guy
i got one of the most amazing
manufacturing and distribution deals
with samsung textile division out of
that
those two partners of ours norman and
bruce weisfeld have been like my
brothers for the last 30 years
the deal came out of totally of my
ignorance and me feeling at the lowest
point in my life and negotiated
ignorance
but they understood where i was coming
from at least and they had empathy and
they educated me on why they did it now
being a shark on shark tank who gets
pitched every day yes i wouldn't answer
my calls either i would just say hey man
i'm sorry i'm looking around do you mind
you know what i mean i mean is it okay
for me to
entertain somebody else um but you know
life is funny god is good and uh you
know it worked out
the lens of perspective can sometimes be
laser focused no doubt about that damon
john here on
on just getting started i want to pause
my conversation with damon for a second
and before we
get back to daymond john and finding out
what's going on with him in the here and
now and of course i got to ask him about
shark tank
let me tell you about our friends at
grove collaborative the sponsor that's
helping
bring you today's edition of just
getting started
i think we can all agree that running to
the store has been pretty stressful
lately
and there's nothing worse than
forgetting something on your list and
needing to make
multiple trips shopping from home
essentials should be easy and convenient
and that's where grove collaborative
comes in
grove is the online marketplace that
delivers healthy home beauty and
personal care products directly to you
with grove you don't have to shop
multiple stores or search endlessly
online to get all the natural goods you
need for you and your family plus
shipping is fast and free on your first
order
join over two million households who
have trusted grove collaborative to make
their
homes happier and healthier making the
switch
to natural products folks has never been
easier for a limited time
when my listeners go to grove dot co
eisen you'll get to choose a free gift
with your first order of thirty dollars
or more but
you have to use our special code so go
to grove
dot co slash eisen to get your exclusive
offer that's grove dot
co slash eisen now back to my
conversation with damon john
let's talk about the here and now damon
john what does damon dawn demand
what are we doing now uh so people could
just um
i'll give you the floor what is what is
that damon donned a map damon on the man
listen you know i think that we're a
great time uh for people
who are as you see in many things when
people dial back
like oh wait when things came like uber
and airbnb
people are creating a lot of businesses
now and with all my books and with all
the stuff i do on shark tank and
everything else there are a lot of
people that feel that
uh they need things a little laid out
for them so what i
created was uh an amazing digital course
with
all the most commonly asked questions
everything from the difference of a
patent to a trademark to how to find
funding where to find funding when's the
right time to find funding
and i put it all together on this course
called damon on demand
because i want people to learn from my
20 million dollars worth of mistakes
trust me uh you don't want to call
future partners and curse them out
uh mostly most people right now probably
have common sense about that
but i put more technical things in there
about how to build a company
because a lot of people that i see that
i try to invest in they're not
investable
they cannot structurally take in the
money
a lot of times that's what happens to
people so
damon on demand is all of that bundled
into one it is uh
you know it is something i think that is
of great great value that i created
because i just realized
there's so much misinformation out there
um and hopefully due to all my years of
hopefully
educating people the right way they they
know that i'm gonna come to them and
give them what they need
well it's not just that too i know you
talk a lot about financial
literacy and how you know and i think
that's an important thing to mention
here as well for people who are trying
to you know how many people have a good
idea but they may not have the financial
literacy how to
connect those dots and make it work and
also understand
you know what uh what a what a balance
sheet would could even look like
um so how would you
how would you approach that uh if
somebody is trying to become more
financially
literate yeah so exactly you know listen
we grew up in a we grow up in a world
and a time when the education system is
broken
and financial literacy is something that
we should be taught in school
just like we're taught shop you know i i
always say
i'm not sure rich if you or i are going
to need to go build a birdhouse but i
promise you we're going to need to
balance a checkbook whether we're
running a fortune 500 company
or running a household checkbook and we
don't have financial literacy
so you you know kids end up going to
school and getting out of school
at 18 years old and getting to the level
where they can now acquire 300 or 500
000
in student debt that they won't pay
until they're 45 years old for education
they're not really certain that they
want to take
so financial literacy is something that
is extremely important
it's not how much you make it's how much
you retain i was on
i did something called black
entrepreneurs day had shaquille o'neal
as one of my great guests and i wanted
people to be again vulnerable
and he said when he made his first check
he didn't realize that he had to pay
taxes
[Laughter]
you know no taxes though do they i mean
no i mean uh yeah i'm you know i could
make a joke that at lsu they probably
didn't take his taxes out of that check
either but i don't want to se i don't
want to go there
but you know or blue chips we saw
obviously we played in blue chips no but
hey look
i've i've been to many rookie symposiums
uh
with the nfl and there are with the
players association
back when there was a rookie symposium
where all the drafted rookies were in a
room together and at a symposium
there was a balancing the checkbook um
breakout session and a lot of a lot of
young studs big men on campus now hoping
to be in the nfl
they didn't know no idea zero yeah
i i sometimes go oh house also i answer
questions that people don't know you
know why because
finances scare people but they have to
deal with them one way or another a lot
of people
don't know what something called capital
gains is or
you know or or and how to reduce your
taxes and it is american to pay your
taxes
and or how when a check comes in what do
you do listen i came from a community
where we thought you're supposed to put
the money under the bed
and and cash is a depreciating asset but
i would never open a bank account
why because for some reason i believe
the bank is mean and they're going to
take my money no
if i screwed up and not paid my taxes
and and they have to freeze it that has
nothing to do with me
but i would pay five percent a five
percent cost to have my check cash that
means
if i'm making thirty thousand dollars a
year
or let's say i'm making uh uh you know
uh five
fifty thousand dollars a year twenty
five hundred is just to cash my check
when that's not financial intelligence
because if you put that in the bank
uh over the course of 10 years you know
in in some stocks
increasing about 10 to you know whatever
15
a year averaging over you know that 2
500 is probably going to be
probably about 30 000 you know that you
saved you just spent that on
cash in your check anyway financial
intelligence is extremely important
whether you're buying widgets
or whether you're buying bread you know
uh you know for the home
so uh and then on march 9th you're
already a
a two-time best-selling author from the
new york times you got powershift coming
out on
march 9th what's that about yeah
powershift uh coming out on paperback on
march 9th what uh
what do you want people to know about
that well you know it takes you about
it takes me about a a year to write a
book this is my fifth book
and the reason why i write them is not
just to write them because i'm dyslexic
it's challenging to write these books
but i write them because whenever people
ask me about things i
recommend a book to go read whether it's
me or tim ferriss or malcolm gladwell
whatever the case is
but i noticed that so many people over
the course of the years were like
oh my god i i read all your books but i
don't have power
to do that or somebody got to give me
power so i wrote this book two years ago
and you know when i hit
because this is the anniversary because
it's the paperback it hit
march last year bang that's cove it hit
sure and um uh i'm glad i wrote it
because this is all about
taking power in your life being able to
shift and being able to
find your destiny so there are four
really key components
to success but to negotiating as well
number one is knowing your why what you
want out of it number two
is building influence number three is to
negotiate what's in the best interest
for the person on the other side of the
table
and uh number four is how to nurture
relationships
shark tank has really ruined a lot of
people's minds
or their perceptions of what a
negotiation is the real world is not
like this
hi sharks i'm damon john and in eight
minutes you got a deal
it is no it's not like that the first
time you meet somebody
it's the dating period and guess what if
you don't get a deal
nurturing that relationship i may
recommend you because i like the way
that you dealt with me
it may not have been for me at the
moment but i may recommend you to rich
i may recommend you to 10 other people
after that so there's so many different
key
things in there and i've highlighted so
many people that i learned from
from um billie jean king who changed the
face of sports to pick bull to kris
jenner
who took three three young ladies that
you for the most part you would think
can't sing
dance play a sport but became number two
or three of the most google
people on the planet uh people like uh
uh mark cuban uh is in there the
billionaire mark cuban who will show you
how to negotiate
uh to empower yourself so that's what
powershift is it's coming out
uh it is march tonight excuse me and it
is uh you know on paperback and people
can get it anywhere and everywhere and i
promise you
it'll help you change the way you think
about negotiation because
life is not what we accept it's what we
negotiate and that is a very popular
saying and i love to remind people about
that
it's great saying um and so before i let
you go i do have to ask you about shark
tank because
i you know the re you know the reason
why the show is so successful is because
people do want to strike it rich they
everybody does think their idea is the
best everybody does think that their
idea could be
a game changer and and and sometimes
they're right
and not only is it just uh throwing
somebody
like a guppy in the shark tank like that
but it's the sharks
who are also ready to eat each other for
the good idea that's right in front of
them it works on
so many levels what is it like when the
cameras are off
and all the sharks are just chilling out
or trying to make deals amongst each
other or what arguing over something
that just went down what is it like
on that set when uh when when the
cameras are not rolling
damon well generally what happens as
soon as the cameras go down i go
and i pull out all the chairs and i
nestle all the sharks in their little
position and then i pull out the white
board and i teach them
another lesson of life um that's what
usually happens but
um for the most part listen you know we
got so many deals coming through that
um when we we we shoot in two different
pods so we see a hundred people in june
and 100 people in
in in september um we shoot 10-hour days
and we only have a half an hour
to as you say drop a deuce and eat and
do whatever the case is
and so we are all that said we are
answering uh
emails and texts and things of that
nature we don't think about the last
deal that went through because
we know we're preparing for another one
uh this last season because we
we were uh you know um restrained due to
covid and we hadn't seen anybody for a
long time we were very happy to see each
other even kevin o'leary i was happy to
see him
that's mr happy and and and that's
pretty much it and i think that um
you know we do relax now in normal times
we go out
you know we go out and we have a good
time sometimes have a dinner and settle
in
who picks up the check who picks up the
check who picks up the check
what we realize we we all pick it up
because we realize that most of the time
we pick up the check and we're at most
tables
and it feels weird so we just all pile
our cards on
on the um you know on on the check and
um
and that generally happened but it is
great to see here we've been doing it
now 12 years going on 13th and it is
amazing
and i'm truly inspired i keep learning
from my other fellow sharks
no sharks have ever been like i just i
left this at home i mean i'll get the
next one that's never
happened where nobody's ever there has
been somebody that a
card was declined um oh come on
come on huh i was declined and it was a
it was somebody who is the last person
that i ever think a card would be
declined and it was obviously a reason
and i was like
i'm gonna get this one so that i can go
down
in history saying that i paid for your
check uh and we probably all know who it
is
uh right now when i when i just said
that but it was the it was the
the one that i would like to say that
for you know oh
okay that had to be a great moment where
like literally you just ate a meal
but now you knew there was a big meal to
be made over that card being rejected
that's it you could tell and you're in
sports if you know he said
whatever dj you know that you know who
that is
of course
that is fantastic all right so before
i let you go damon uh one i guess
you've given so many great pieces of
advice but if there is somebody out
there who
is downloading and listening to this pod
as i hope they do to try and get
inspired to to just get started what
would you say
is the overarching advice that you would
give to somebody
who is thinking of you know either
switching tracks
or starting with an idea that they think
should be and could be a winner wanting
to believe in themselves and feeling
vulnerable what would you say
damon okay yeah good question so
depends on the people around you i want
you to know that you can do it because
every single thing that you see in the
world started off with
one person that had one idea that took
one action so it is doable
another stat is that if you look at the
thousand wealthiest people in the world
on forbes 65 percent of them are
self-made men and women
that means they had no money the true
people who are successful
they take a step forward they act and
they learn and then they repeat
take affordable steps it does not cost
you anything to educate yourself
do not use that you have to go to this
college pick up books listen to this
podcast anything else
keep your day job keep educating
yourself but you gotta understand you're
gonna have to sacrifice something
i slept for three hours a night for five
years working a real officer and working
fubu
but if you do that then what happens is
if you don't bet too much
then you can recover from any mistake
that you make if you educate yourself
you can avoid those mistakes but you
gotta keep
doing that and finding mentors because
mentors
will continue to help you show you when
you're in the right direction
and if you fail if it's something you
love then you spent time doing something
you love it just didn't work out right
now and maybe you'll start all over
again
a little more wisely but you'll be able
to recover damon i really appreciate it
truly i love the chat
uh love that um uh you were kind enough
to say i'll i'll i'll pop on a new pod
uh with me on just getting started i
really appreciate it
truly it is an honor are you kidding me
i'm happy to be here
i got to brag i'm going to brag about
this too in about 10 years when it is
the biggest thing everybody oh yeah you
know rich i was i was on i was
number five or six but i was there i
appreciate that and you tell cuban pay
his bills
okay
[Laughter]
i just threw that one out there that's
damon john right here on just getting
started
damon john everybody that was great uh i
hope you enjoyed that chat
and um you know my new york accent
like i said went away um when i was
starting my broadcasting career up in
redding california and
a lot of folks in northern california
were like what is tournament what does
that mean
um what are you what are you what are
you getting at um
and uh my accent still does come out if
you cut me off in traffic so let's
let's avoid that um but just hearing his
story
you know it kind of gave me an idea that
maybe
as we continue on on this pod i'm gonna
try and
if i can get everybody's epiphany story
but by that i mean just
having the moment where you realize
that you need to change things up or you
realize that the way you're doing things
or the way you're conducting yourself or
the way that things are going
is not to your liking and you have one
of those epiphany moments
and you say i'm going to do something
about it that the power is within you
to find a solution and i'll i'll share
my epiphany story with you right here to
wrap up this episode
before i did um um
go into tv i was in print journalism and
um i graduated the university of
michigan in 1990
and i took a job with my hometown
newspaper the staten island advance or
as the locals would call it the advents
they put the
the uh accent on the first syllable and
so i'm
you know working for the staten island
advance which had me as a summer intern
while i was
with michigan and um um
um not doing sports which is what my
dream was to be
my dream was to be a sportscaster uh if
not a stand-up comedian we can get into
that in future episodes as well maybe
we'll get a comic on as a as a guest
um but the reason why again i'm telling
you this is my epiphany story is i was
covering the police beat
the cop speed going from one police
precinct to another on staten island
there were three of them
and you would hop in a car and go from
one precinct to another to another and
literally stop into the
to the to the precinct and go up to the
desk and ask if there's something going
on
and also look through the uh police
reports for
burglaries because my my um my hometown
newspaper would report which houses got
broken into it's a small town staten
island it's a
size of a medium-sized city in the
united states but in new york city it's
a small part
it's the smallest borough of of new york
city
and uh i remember going from one
precinct to the next and i had this big
huge walkie-talkie next to me where i'm
listening to the police
radio and there was a sheet that i had
police was not my normal beat this was
just on a weekend where i was filling in
for somebody and
you'd hear codes you'd hear like 10 14
10 20 10 25 and every code that was
coming out i was afraid it was like some
you know major uh major
situation going down uh on staten island
i was missing
i was just fearful of missing something
so i'm going from one precinct to the
next and an ambulance zooms by
and i'm thinking okay this might be
something that i need to go cover
and i i followed the ambulance and i
went through some red lights to follow
the ambulance and i
i once the ambulance zoomed off and i
decided i shouldn't continue to
to follow that ambulance because i'm
blowing through red lights i i pulled
over to the side of the road
and i thought to myself what i am doing
right now there is no other way to parse
what i'm doing right now
other than call it what it is ambulance
chasing i was an ambulance chaser
i didn't ever think i would do such a
thing or want to do such a thing that's
not what i was put on the planet to do
uh i didn't go to college for it i
didn't want to do it even as i was doing
it i just was following a
basic instinct to try and be
professional and also fear
of missing a story
and i thought to myself this was i guess
damon john's
red lobster moment where i pulled off to
the side of the road and i'm like
i want to be a sportscaster i do not
want to be an ambulance chaser
how do i make this happen what do i do
i eventually i applied to graduate
school because i was fortunate enough
you heard
as i mentioned damon john's mom took out
another mortgage on
on their house so she could help finance
his business
you know my parents helped me with
student loans
and um i went to grad school and you
know eventually
got to where i wanted to go but not
before i had that
really strange moment of ambulance
chasing and having an epiphany behind
the wheel of a car in staten island new
york
saying i'm an ambulance chaser and i
don't want to be one
and i just sat there and decided i'm
going to take some steps
and that's how in a way i just got
started so every episode of just getting
started is gonna be out every friday so
uh as the kids say the the episode will
drop on friday so keep uh
an eye out for the next episode of just
getting started please do subscribe as
well and give us that
five star rating you know you want to
and if you don't i'll know who you are
i don't usually like to end a thro show
with a threatening note but i just did
and so i guess that's how i'm just
getting started we'll see you next week
[Music]
you